hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys this is the Canon what we use to
explode the pool table that one time
that is correct yeah yeah it's an
absolute Beast even when we use it
safely it's still kind of squeaky bun
time because it's such a powerful thing
that's an absolute Wallop considering
its size a total Wallop Devastation
something else we've used is ballistic
gel we used it before with a sort of
very high caliber rifle yeah
and it had devastating effect right and
I thought
will ballistic gel be able to contain
a cue ball I mean it's slightly slower
projectile than obviously the the rifle
was a lot slower yeah but still it's
like heftier and bigger if we catch the
pool ball in the ballistic gel I'll eat
the ballistic gel
[Laughter]
on the 4K I'm at a thousand frames a
second slightly behind a bit wide and
over here for the close-up of the
ballistics gel we're on the TMX 7510 82
000 frames a second and then long
trigger cable so we can hide around
there the ballistic gel was melting in
the Sun so we've covered it with this
but now it's got imprints of the the
jacket in it so perfect like it's just
you can't win you cannot win
it's pretty clear okay how long's the
fuse about 45 seconds give or take
plenty of time to get over there behind
the berm yeah I've got the trigger
around there already perfect
oh my is it in there what
oh not as Hefty as we thought
isn't that it
well there was only 30 grams right of
powder you can have up to 55. maybe it
needs the 455. that is so cool it looks
like a plant from another planet the
hole retracted to be so much smaller
than the ball wow it's like a perfectly
circular hole look at that the bullet
holes go quite tight but this is like
this is going to be too graphic well
maybe if you keep fingering it
you can see the propellant in the gel
there oh yeah it's embedded in like a
few mil I am so shocked wow
just getting gold
it goes pretty deep in doesn't it yeah
the the shock does that is so much smoke
I think I need to be further out to the
side yeah because the smoke is wider
than the ball yes the ball is further
forward than the smoke and comes out of
it yeah it's just encroaching on a angle
exactly all right let's have a look at
the other angle oh
interesting fireworks France again oh
the same pattern on the uh yeah it's not
it's spinning a little bit
look at that just it's like a splash
Mark isn't it it is and that went back
down to
that size it really reminds me of like
when the T1000 gets shot yeah it's true
you can see the whole back like the the
reflection now the whole background look
at that following it in going inside
getting sucked in WoW went way further
than it landed
oh yeah because it causes the elasticity
like to bring it back it's gonna get
pulled back absolutely sucks there must
be immense pressure on the front side of
this
it like collapses before it pulls it
back
elastics it
but way further than I thought because
it the fact that it made it three
quarters of the way in but ended up
about a quarter of the way in it got
sucked way it got sucked back through
almost 50 of the gel what you're
forgetting as well is it's getting
sucked back quickly oh yeah that's true
this is quick yeah it's Landing very
little and then the smoke comes all
right maybe we'll slide it over a little
bit because that is uh the smoke came in
before we really saw everything but I
think we saw the the meat of it yeah we
lost a little bit of information then
the whole thing just moved forward very
slightly just judged forward and then
it's just like
it's got I'd say twice as far as it
landed that is insane I said I'd have to
eat there didn't I
do you remember
start snacking oh I was just blown away
that it was in there I forgot all about
you eating it why don't we just put 55
grabs in let's put maximum power loading
and just flip it the other way around
all right let's flip it like like that
and it and the new ball has to go past
its its brother okay and we can then
measure the distance and the difference
in going from 30 grams to 55 if it stays
in there it's a work of art there's
isn't it I think if we if we collect the
other one as well just uplight it I'm
just gonna turn it into a lamp
it actually looks like the simulation of
a black hole and just like there's a
disc in front there's a disc at the top
there's a disc at the bottom around the
side yeah
before we get to this beefy Cannon
finale I'd like to briefly talk about
the sponsor of this video better help as
some of you may know at the beginning of
2018 I went through a rather traumatic
event that left me with severe PTSD and
I found that talking to a therapist was
the best decision I made when it came to
processing that event
and not thinking about it every single
day bet helps main goal is to make
therapy more accessible and affordable
you just fill out a few questions online
you'll get matched with a therapist from
that point on it's all remote meetings
and there's no judgment if you don't get
on well with that therapist you can
easily switch to a different one at no
extra cost you don't need a traumatic
event to start therapy I still do mine
weekly just to talk things through and
even gain new skills for coping with
stuff in the future I've found it
extremely useful beyond the help with
the PTSD if you're feeling a bit numb or
struggling literally with anything
consider doing some online therapy with
better help if you click the link in the
description you'll be helping out the
channel but also you'll get 10 off your
first month big old thanks to betterhelp
for sponsoring this video back to the
action I reckon it will end up here okay
I'm going to predict this to be
different it goes all the way through
all right you can eat the block then no
no no that's a ridiculous bet to make
come on it's gone 25 seconds now all
right
the thing is if it heat changes and the
fuse gets hotter the burn time shortens
oh interesting
and there's more propellant in it so it
might blow sooner because the
propellants Fuller up in the chamber
anytime the next five seconds five four
three two one bang
no way it's way more precise than it was
last time summer yeah oh well that's
different that's a change
oh it's out of there oh it looked gone
it like got diverted by the other ball
it like must have hit it and then like
bounced slightly and like took a slight
deflection come on now that's mental
it's my bucket now it's a bit Mucky my
point of aim there goes my lamp idea oh
no so
oh gosh
so my point yeah I could I could make it
clean again I can make it clean again oh
it's a bigger it's a much more yeah it's
like come on
you know exactly where the ball went
it's just saved was this bit of damage
here before Oh no because I think oh
yeah the ball shattered what
no it has as well
that's cool it's crap like yeah look
that bit of damage there is obviously
from when the ball hit it it's pushed it
down and forced it down and cracked the
ball that means I wonder if the other
one cracked oh
oh no oh it did oh it went there maybe
it was just literally just oh you know
what it is
before when we did the ballistic gel
remember it like lets it out and it kind
of grabs onto it a little bit oh so it
must have released and like it must have
like released and like flung it to the
side gosh
wow
look at that opening it's so big it's so
big it's such like a mega tunnel and
then it goes thin after it hits the ball
shutter and it's still blurry that's
really fast you know really home in in a
one thousandth of a second it moved from
here to there that's fast that is fast
oh so you hit the yeah I think it just
swung out like you said I think it just
sloughed out went straight down and just
bounced over there yeah the other piece
the smaller piece went quite high so
maybe the other footage will let us know
better where it went okay the absolute
peppering has begun which is
yeah obviously you can't really see it
on the on there anymore oh it's looking
way faster I wonder if Amazon much
bigger Splash at least twice as far
that's questionable there's no
what's crazy to me is how late whoa oh
God it caused like new cavitation on the
other four
oh man I think the ball hit the table it
did it will have done it will have
exited because you can see the wound
marks on the on the gel so the ball that
was in there slammed into the table but
I think landed back where it was so the
ball is split already yeah that might be
what helped it out is because it was
Jagged it might have just cut cut
through a lot easier all came out of
that tiny little wood okay look it's
just releasing around that it's just
birthing it yeah it barely made it
though look it's made an inch out barely
moving forwards at all you could have
caught that
if you were if you had a death wish
that's great that's wicked there was a
bit more information go back on and see
something
what's interesting is you see how much
the the whole how big the hole it made
is right but the outside of the
ballistic
you barely moved we always seem to have
the right exact size of ballistic gel
for interesting stuff Perfect Isn't it
yeah I love the fact that this ball made
it over here and they just went all the
way back there yeah that was great I
love footage like that it's like you it
happens you see the end result and
you're like well how did we get to that
and then the footage just tells you
everything that's what's so great about
having these cameras it's like we don't
have to guess but it's fun to guess
before yeah it really is look at the
evidence to be like this is I think what
happened and then get you know more
excited when we see the actual footage
well hopefully you like watching us send
various objects into ballistic shell we
can do more let us know in the comments
hopefully you enjoyed that video make
sure you subscribe and here's another
video for you to watch see you next time
all right you better get started
you want to catch up
oh hang on it went through so you don't
have to eat it
foreign